ha
no you say something falaya the cunning
ploy to make sure we get standing
ovations by just making your stand Wow
well look um for years I I stood where
you are now I joined this party when I
was 16 I've watched some great liberal
leaders give some incredible speeches
steel Ashdown Kennedy Campbell Clegg
imagine following in their footsteps
to say it Alana is an understatement of
epic proportions
I remember sitting in the winter gardens
at the Blackpool conference watching
paddy give his first leaders speech when
I was 18 I remember feeling not just
inspired by incredibly guilty because
I'd left home impressed in that morning
and there on the kitchen table was my
round of focus leapers and I'm not
delivered them yet
I got home and discovered that my mother
had done them for me just bless her and
so I get to join I'll get to lead the
party I joined as a kid thank you thank
you very much
I I will work every day to repay the
trust you have put in me but there is
someone else I want to say thank you to
as well and that is Norman there's more
there's more
Norman Norman is an outstanding liberal
who's being a mentor of mine since I was
first elected in 2005 I got really bored
of hearing myself speak during the
leadership campaign but I never got
bored with Norman as I as I consider
Norman's achievements on improving
mental health I am reminded how vital it
is that we win elections so that we can
make that kind of difference again
if there were if there were more Norman
lambs in politics people's opinions of
politicians would be so much better they
said of Joe Grimm and that he gave
politics a good name now I don't go
around comparing people to Joe Graham
and lightly but no one is exactly in
that mold I am proud of his achievements
in government I am incredibly proud to
work alongside Norman as we rebuild our
party to Norman and to all of his team
you fought a brilliant campaign we urge
oh you a massive debt of thanks
so do you remember where you were on the
morning at the 8th of May I don't ever
want to feel that way again
I was completely gutted I watched people
I'd worked alongside four years lose
their seats well I knew that every
single one of them are given blood sweat
and tears their constituents and for
their country
it felt overwhelming utterly desperate
heartbreaking but that morning something
happened that snap me out of it I saw a
great leader give an incredible speech
Nick Nick stood up after what must have
been one of the most appalling nights of
his life and with dignity and humility
and great great clarity he said and I
read out to you on the morning of the
most crushing blow to the Liberal
Democrats since our Party was founded it
is easy to imagine that there is no road
back but there is because there is no
path to a fairer greener freer Britain
without British liberalism showing the
way this is a very dark hour for our
party but we cannot and will not allow
decent liberal values to be extinguished
overnight fear and grievance have won
liberalism has lost but it is more
precious than ever and we must keep
fighting for it dary
so we
there was not a dry house or dry eye in
the Ferran adrià that's the Liberal
Democrats for you in the Ferran
household at least there was not a dry
eye mine included to go through what
Nick had been through that night and
come out with words of such passion and
gravitas and sanity well that is the
mark of a truly remarkable man and all
of a sudden instead of feeling desperate
I felt proud proud of every single one
of my colleagues in Parliament proud of
Nick and all of our ministers who served
in coalition government Vince and edge
Joel and Danny Lynn Norman Simon and
Susan and everyone else you get involved
in politics to get stuff done well we
got stuff done and we owe it all to me
so
the knick speech made the hairs on the
back of my neck stand on end I felt
proud to be a liberal Democrat and you
know what I clearly wasn't the only one
because what happened next constitutes a
phenomenon 17,000 people joined our
party since that dark morning and that
is a phenomenon 17,000 people chose to
do the same thing at the same time for
the same reasons without anybody asking
them and Hosting's up and down the
country what has happened is this Norman
has got to ask first so I get to do it
now okay because I was backstage and I
can I can here but I can't see people's
hands going up raise your hands if you
join the party since the 7th of May
thank you
that is a new a new army a new army of
Liberal Democrat members 17,000 and
rising who are not prepared to see
liberalism disappear in our country
people question how can we come back
from such a devastating defeat well I
can introduce you to 17,000 ounces
you know
it's almost like you can see the penny
dropping for the British public first
with the Queen's speech and then with
the budget what's this the toys want to
scrap the Human Rights Act they want to
snoop on our emails they want to flog
off Housing Association homes they want
to cut billions of pounds and some of
the poorest families in our country if
only was some way to stop them all right
that's what the Liberal Democrats were
doing and now day after day we get
reminders Tuesday's today program
Lister's being told that promoting equal
pay was a liberal Democrat policy not a
Tory one yesterday the Guardian writing
how Nick Clegg has fought so hard to get
big money out of politics are you
alright are you okay
don't apologise are you alright that's
okay
you don't need to stand sit down we're
all right
here's warming alright so yeah the Today
program and the Guardian this week
giving us plaudits for our time in
office and I kind of thought in the
nicest and most generous possible way
you could have mentioned that before the
election and
without without inviting any gags about
how many of us can fit in a big yellow
taxi they they say you don't know what
you've got till it's gone well you know
what we're not gone we are not gone and
we are not gone we are not gone and no
matter how tough the fight there is no
one else for us to go no other movement
dies home you know growing up where I
grew up in the circumstances I grew up
in you might have thought I should have
been Labor I grew up in a Terrace on a
main road in Preston I was brought up on
my mum often struggling to put food on
the table I was politicized by watching
Cathy come home I should have been Labor
Shirley but I wasn't why not
because I saw that Labour would just
part of the system small see
conservatives to parties happy to
collude and protect the establishment
locking out people like us I was an
outsider
I was an outsider I was outsider and I
wanted a party that spoke for me let's
vote for me and let you think for
yourself that wanted to win elections so
they could change lives not just so they
could feel self-important and lives
needed changing a difference needed to
be made I learned at first hand that
nothing robs you of your freedom more
than poverty and poor housing
I also learned
I also learn that dependency can stifle
freedom just as butch I saw the
potential of people to change their own
lives if only we gave them the freedom
to learn the freedom to earn the freedom
to be the best that they can be in the
election campaign which has just gone
we weren't bad at telling people what we
were against but frankly we were a bit
terrible at telling people what we were
for so let's be crystal clear or the
Liberal Democrats are for we are the
party that sees the best in people not
the worst with a party that believes
that the role of government is to help
us to be the best we can be no matter
who we are or what our background that
is it
that is our mission guys our mission we
see people as individuals not as
opposing tribes lined up against each
other across borders we favor
cooperation over isolation your failure
is not my success we stand up against
the abuse of power for Entrepreneurship
and individual endeavor which the
immigration as a blessing not a curse
and we value we value
and we do that because we value the
contribution every single individual has
to make to this beautiful country of
ours as the world changes around us we
see the opportunities and not just the
dangers because we see the best in
people we trust people that's why we
stand up for the individual against the
state why we stand up for the minority
against the majority while we stand up
for the outsider against the
establishment because that is not just
what we do is who we are
is it is who we are because despite what
happened on May the 7th this is still an
open generous and tolerant country a
liberal country and the pathway to our
revival is visible even in that terrible
result because what we saw is people
still looking for answers they are less
tied to the old tribes of self-interest
than was ever the case in the past even
with the collapse in our own support
over one third of us could not bring
ourselves to vote for Tories or labour
so if we work hard and we strive to
understand each other not just people's
concerns but their values we can win
again
you know the Dutch they are so liberal
they've got two liberal parties hey Oda
thought it and and one of them the one
that's most like us be 66 were the
smaller party in a coalition and then in
2006 they got stuffed they got 2 percent
3 MPs that came 9th Wow these are the
good times but you know what just scroll
forward to last year the European
elections 9th no first first so revival
is out there is a model we can copy
survival and revival is in our grasp
have hope have courage have belief
July 2015
well the start for our 2020 campaign
begins right now and the fight back will
begin well beyond Westminster
Westminster is only one brick in the
governance of this country it is a place
I come to do a job for the people who
elected me but it is utterly divorced
from the reality of people's lives home
for me is Westmoreland surrounded by
lakes mountains at vibrant self-reliant
communities who share my disdain for the
Westminster bubble and the challenges we
face in the lakes or anyone else amongst
the cities towns and villages of these
islands are ones which we can help to
address wherever there are Liberal
Democrats in Parliament okay but also in
the town halls in the city halls the
National Assembly in Wales and Holyrood
even Brussels next year in Scotland
Wales in London we will see elections
with the potential to change the lives
of millions of people those elections
are utterly critical they matter me just
as much as 2020 and they are the first
staging posts of the come back ward by
Ward Council by council seat by seat we
will fight and we will win and if the
Tories really are determined to make
everyone have a metro mayor - we'll just
have to win those elections as well
I I am up for this you ought for this
I'm optimistic but it will take hard
work guts and bloody mindedness there
will be defeat and in justices
witnessing winning has never been easy
we have no automatic right to bounce
back we have to do it ourselves but we
will I am going to make sure of it you
see losing robs you of the ability to
make a difference as a party we have
been proven right so many time on Kosovo
on Iraq on climate change on the
financial crisis but you know what I am
fed to the back teeth of being right and
losing elections
as as David Steele once said I am NOT
interested in power without principles
but I've only faintly interested in
principles without power
there is nothing grubbing about wanting
to win you can't change people's lives
from second place so here's my challenge
to you pick award any Ward win it next
May don't care how is it on May the 7th
winning elections isn't rocket science
but it is a science
do it enjoy the fight enjoy stunning the
opposition as the comeback kids prove
them wrong and be uplifted by the
difference you can make when you win we
may not be able to change britain from
the top down just for the moment but we
can change lives from the bottom up
that's community policy
and community politics is about
mobilizing our communities to build the
homes that we need to win a local battle
in the war against climate change to get
the resources to strengthen our schools
I want more MPs and before that I want
hundreds and hundreds of new Liberal
Democrat councillors immersed in their
communities living their values by
getting things done step by step we will
change people's lives for better and as
we do that we will regain their trust
you see our survival revival our rebirth
our rebuild will happen in communities
in councils in common rooms away from
the stuffy corridors of Westminster and
Whitehall many watched the horror of
election night unfurl standing as
spectators all across the country
devastated by what they saw powerless to
affect what was happening well I'm
telling you now here in this hall and
around the country you are not
spectators you are players you don't
like the way Britain is now governed
that makes two of us let's stop
complaining about it let's do something
we will make our own look and we will do
it together it is time for the Liberal
Democrats to win again
so so none of us join the Liberal
Democrats as a smart career movie that
is because we've never seen this as a
career
that's for the others this is a vocation
a mission so the Tories and labor have
their vested interests and we say we
have no vested interest actually we do
our vested interests of the people in
our street our town our village our
vested interest is your vested interest
our liberal voice is your liberal voice
so let's together make our liberal voice
stronger if you care about human right
join us if you think you shouldn't have
your email snooped on join us if you
think everyone deserves a decent home
join us if you think it is wrong to
demonize immigrants the young the poor
foreigners Brussels the English the
Scots join us if you are fed up of
self-satisfied politicians ambitious for
themselves and unambitious for their
country then guess what you are a
liberal embrace that diagnosis it is an
utterly decent and British condition so
for joy
so here's a cold
here is up here is our fall tonight
liberals of Britain if you want a better
britain than you need to do something
about it come and be part of the most
joyful inspiring and worthwhile comeback
in political history because that
comeback starts right now
right here it starts with us thank you